our next guest i'm so excited started
his own hot dog business at just 11
years old
i know and two years later his dogs
nabbed the number five spot on peta's
top 10 vegan hot dogs in the country and
now at age 14 mason wright is the
youngest restaurant owner in the state
of georgia and guess what he's here
hi mason
i miss you how are you
i am really fangirling out i have been
so excited to meet you
thank you so much and this has been i've
been so excited to meet you too so let
me get this straight you were in new
york you saw a hot dog cart and what
happened
all i saw was hot dog carts and
superheroes in new york town square
and
that's when i knew i could take this
business concept back to atlanta and so
i did i made a deal with all my family
members that as long as i have good
grades
could you buy me this hot dog cart and i
will go an entire semester and the new
year with all a's
well done to you and your family now you
actually auditioned for shark tank and
you said like bombing was the best thing
that could have ever happened will you
explain that
yeah when i went there and i was
auditioning i got really
scared and nervous i was gonna mess up
and i did but as i was walking
i saw the president of morehouse i ran
up to him i told him my business [ __ ]
and then he said as long as you have all
a's you can sell on my campus i said
amazing
thank you so much
and from there
tons of the college students kept coming
that people from clark spellman
morehouse students when they would get
there super early it was amazing well
and it's perfect you know you're running
from class to class you need a snack i
mean that's why manhattan has so many
hot dog carts they get it you get it is
it easy or is it challenging to run a
full-time business and get straight a's
i would say it's half and half i've
always been a good student and i make
sure that i get my work done and i'm
also homeschooled
and my mom says a's matter
numbies always
and i start my school day from
from six i get here at 11 once i finish
all my work i get to work and it's been
a great experience i'm so inspired by
i don't even know what to start with
your work ethic your
scholastic ethic your wonderful family
who seems to have a
delightful balance of enabling you to
have your dreams but being responsible
you know i worked as a kid myself and i
just think the way you and your family
are going about it is just
fantastic and i know you get your
restaurant supplies from
restaurant depot and
i have a little something here
from them to you they wanted to give you
a 5 000 gift card
to put directly into your business
and your next shopping trip so
um
thank you very much
i'm trying to continue my excitement be
professional
thank you so very much for that
okay but that's not all because
i heard that um you're obviously a fan
of superheroes which has to do with your
business model and that iron man is your
favorite
check this out
where is he
drew where is he where's mason right let
me see him
oh
my man
young
entrepreneurs small business now more
than ever right you have a
vision you make it real
this is the american dream you
are a complete rock star my friend and
by the way i want to try one of these
veggie dogs i hear they're award winning
um barrymore do me a solid and hook me
up with this kid i need to know him
oh my lenta that was iron man i know and
i know that you love superheroes and i
know you love iron man and so i reached
out to downey and he sent you that
message
thank you so much um
i will definitely send him
a award-winning
video
thank you so much oh oh my gosh
mason i think you're a superhero i
really do
the fact that
you saw something and you came up with
an idea and a business plan and you
loved superheroes and you wanted to feed
people
and be smart about your approach on
everything i just my admiration for you
is endless thank you so much that made
my day
thank you mason
i should be here oh
mason we're going to check in with you
and see how everything's going is that
cool i'd like to stay in touch
yes most definitely
excellent and congratulations on your
awards peta like top five vegan dogs in
the country youngest business owner in
all of georgia i can't wait for the next
award you win thank you mason good luck
with everything and we'll be in touch
[Music]